mais vous le pensez vraiment absolument
mon chéri mines absolument les critères
de la beauté sont les mêmes pour tout le
monde à part bonne et moi monsieur noah
mais là je n'ai pas très bien compris ce
que vous valez de le dire mais ce n'est
pas grave aux séries mise
je disais les critères de la beauté
ce sont les les raisons qui font que
certaines choses sont bel et bien ces
raisons sont bien évidemment les mêmes
pour tout le monde
il décide par exemple je me moi je
trouve qu'une chose est belle que vous
vous la trouvez l'aide ça ça peut
arriver non c'est que vous faites une
faute de goût mais en fait pourquoi moi
pourquoi pas vous raymond roux vrai mais
j'espère qu'il s'agit d'une plaisanterie
peut vous savez parfaitement que je ne
peux pas faire de faute de goût pour sûr
j'aurais dû m'en douter mais cette fois
ci le sujet cela que je ne suis pas de
votre avis non ce n'est pas parce que
deux personnes n'ont pas la même opinion
sur la beauté de quelque chose que l'une
des deux a tort et l'autre en raison
monsieur du snob comment dit les goûts
et les couleurs ça ne se discute pas
pareil je suis tout à fait de votre avis
faites chez des snobs
il faut respecter l'opinion de chacun
comment mon cher françois
vous me décevez beaucoup vous un garçon
de goût nous voulions le chai du snob
teulé est ce que par exemple vous
aimeriez portait une chemise comme la
mienne elle ne vous plaît pas et bien
moi je me plais beaucoup à et je suis
sûr que le facteur est très contente son
uniforme pour sûr ça alors maintenant
monsieur du snad imaginer que tout le
monde est exactement les mêmes bijoux
mais ce serait formidable mais non ce
serait épouvantable à imaginer que vous
arriviez dans le jardin ni leurs enfants
avec votre joli costume
oui et que tout le monde est exactement
le même que vous monsieur beauchesne le
facteur ou enfin tous les habitants de
l'île aux enfants
eh bien monsieur de ce noble plus
personne ne fait attention à vous mais
vous avez raison il faut soir que l'on
sait pour une table tu ne vais pas
réfléchir ça
mais ce casino tarifs pour sûr je n'ai
jamais vu plus rien sénégal ne doit qu'à
venir on peut vous de td oui monsieur du
sne aux arts ils ont dit nous ce qu'il
t'arrive tu as un mouchoir s'il te plaît
mais moi je me retiens alors casimir
c'est très grave rend cet épouvantail
sur moi je te suis très inquiète france
moi mais par le dans casino mais ne vous
impatientez pas monsieur du snob enfin
il est très ému
pardonnez moi j'ai j'ai perdu mon ours
en peluche à ce n'est que ça mais c'est
très grave
je ne peux pas m'endormir ça mon ours en
peluche mais encore une fois le
challenge et comprendre que nous nous
attachons pas tous la même importance
aux objets bombay que j'ai mis en août
en fait pas bon nous allons aider à le
retrouver
nous allons fouiller toute l'île vous
êtes vraiment des titres est grâce à mes
bonbons à la description précise de
tendance en plus cela facilitera les
recherches seraient oui c'est c'est un
amour chaari en peluche à ab parfait
nous voilà bien renseignés non mais vous
un petit peu casimir tu n'as pas
d'autres renseignements
oui oui c'est c'est la plus belle ours
en peluche du monde pokémon mais cela
devient très intéressant le plus bel
ours en peluche du monde on n'aura pas
grand mal à le retrouver
nous allons nous répartir les différents
quotidiens ou facteur vous prenez ce
secteur ici bien avoue jean françois
monsieur du snav chargé vous de ce côté
je te pète à présent mais j'accepte
volontiers un émoi bien bien moi je
prends ce secteur est casimir ne t'en
fais pas nous allons retrouver le plus
d'ennemis en peluche du monde
merci
[Musique]
[Rires]
ils ne reviennent pas je ne reverrais
jamais montbel ours en peluche on a je
suis malheureux magazine rsa à françois
tu n'as rien trouvé mais c'est la garde
ou à dès que je les ai vus j'ai compris
que c'était le plus bel ours en peluche
du monde
mais ce n'est pas mon ours tu ne touches
pas bien aussi et vous mais le mien
c'est le plus bel ours où tout le monde
casimir je suis désolé mon fils à sidy
gaye
c'est moins voyons ah bon ça ça n'a pas
l'air d'aller un ben non j'ai échoué
facteurs je n'ai pas trouvé le bonus en
plus ça ne m'étonne pas françois
pourquoi dites vous ça pour quoi
parce que le plus bel ours en peluche du
nom de la série c'est moi c'est vous
c'est moi qui l'ait trouvée ah bon il
est superbe raconte mes félicitations
faire taire alors casimir que les
heureux maintenant pas du tout ben c'est
une pure merveille
bah oui mais ce n'est pas le mien
et bien j'arrive à temps mes chers amis
vous avez trouvé bien sûr cher ami
seules les personnes ayant un goût c'est
sûr que le mieux pour retrouver le plus
bel ours en peluche du moment comme on
le voit si il est extraordinaire pas aux
seuls les affreux ce petit bijou doute
un peu lui chaut que du mur tu exagères
bon il n'est peut-être pas trop mais
comparé au mien il ya allô allô casimir
est soit je m'en viens tout n'est
peut-être pas perdu
tazi muedra lieu c'est toujours la même
chose quand on a joué trop laid il faut
casser
il laisse traîner au milieu du jardin au
lieu de l'orangé c'est ce qu'ils
viennent de faire avec ce vieil os tout
l'abîmé cette chose-là cette horreur aux
techniques ne nous écoute pas on brave
petit ours tués vraiment le plus belle
course du monde a décidément de casimir
est stupide pas du tout monsieur du snob
et
je comprends très bien kazimiya ce que
l'on aime le plus on trouve toujours que
ce sont les plus beaux du monde et là je
suis sûr que tous nos amis sont bien
d'accord clavecin voyez-vous monsieur du
sud revient c'est de la philosophie
[Musique]